The
term crowdfunding, a process by which a person
raises money by asking others for small donations,
has become popular online during the past
few years.
Websites like Kickstarter and Indiegogo offer
individuals a platform from which to make
their cases to an international community.
Mike Hayes of Illinois used crowdfunding to
pay for all four years of his college education
at the University of Illinois.
He asked strangers to send him a penny and
received donations from all fifty states in
the United States and across the world.
But he did it long before the World Wide Web
(See: Who Invented the Web) or crowdfunding
websites; he did it in 1987.
Eighteen year old Mike Hayes graduated from
high school in 1987 and enrolled in a science
program at the University of Illinois.
He had earned $2,500 from a job working at
a drugstore, but that money would not go far
to pay the four years of tuition and fees
that added up to around $28,000 (about $57,000
today).
His middle class family already put his four
older siblings through college.
While Hayes’s parents, his father a pharmacist
and his mother a school teacher, would have
helped him to pay, Hayes decided he did not
want his parents going into debt for him.
Thus, he came up with the idea to convince
2.8 million people to each donate a penny
to him.
Towards this end, he approached famed Chicago
Tribune columnist Bob Greene for help.
Greene began his career as a journalist before
becoming a nationally syndicated columnist
with his column appearing in over 200 newspapers
across the nation.
He had worked for the Tribune for almost ten
years when he received Hayes’s request.
Greene liked the idea and shared Hayes’s
request with his readers on September 6, 1987.
He told them who Mike was and why he wanted
Greene’s readers to send him pennies.
“‘Just one penny,’ Hayes said.
‘A penny doesn’t mean anything to anyone.
If everyone who is reading your column looks
around the room right now, there will be a
penny under the couch cushion, or on the corner
of the desk, or on the floor.
That’s all I’m asking.
A penny from each of your readers.’”
Greene admitted that he and Hayes knew the
biggest obstacle they faced was getting people
to actually send in the pennies.
So he encouraged his readers to put down the
column they were reading and send a penny
to Mike right then and there.
He drove the point home by making sure to
include Mike’s PO Box address, twice.
Hayes’ plan worked.
Less than a month after Greene’s column
was published, he had already received approximately
$23,000.
All of that money came in more than 70,000
pieces of mail and in the form of pennies,
nickels, dimes, and quarters (many of which
had to be hand washed to get the glue or other
sticky residue used to attach them to the
envelope off before they could be put in the
bank’s automatic coin counter, which actually
broke three times processing all the coins
he was receiving).
Mike also received much easier to process
checks and paper bills.
Three people mailed checks for $100.
The post office received so much mail one
day that rather than count it, they simply
quantified it in feet, and the postmaster
reported to Bob Greene that at its peak there
was 26 feet of mail in one day.
The money kept pouring into the PO Box, and
Hayes ended up with more than the equivalent
of 2.8 million pennies he needed to pay for
college.
He graduated in 1991 with a degree in food
science and student loan free.
When he spoke to Bob Greene for a follow up
on their original column, he said there was
a thousand dollars left over after all his
college expenses were paid.
Hayes decided to give the remaining money
to a college student from one of the families
that sent him money.
He and his family had kept a large portion
of the letters, totaling about 90,000 in the
end, and he decided he’d award the money
via randomly selecting one letter from the
pile and then contacting the person to see
if they or their children had need of $1,000
for college.
If they did not, he would draw another letter
until he found a family that he could help.
In the end, Mike had this to say about the
whole thing, “I just want to express my
thanks to everyone… right now I’m feeling
that the world is a pretty great place.”
Besides money, Mike also got quite a few college
girls sending him letters with pictures and
their phone numbers, including some from the
University he was attending.
He even got a letter from Miss America 1983,
Debra Maffett, saying how much she admired
him.
In the end, he claimed he rebuffed all advances
as he already had a girlfriend back home who
was a junior in high school
at the time.